hey everyone it's my bottles from water
flows calm and I want to tell you about
an upcoming training workshop that we
have for free on Tuesday September 19th
it's with investor inspiration you know
they do these semi-regularly
you know online trading conferences and
I'll be speaking on this one on Tuesday
September 19th I'll be part of a lineup
of six other traders where we're gonna
discuss trading and what works for each
of us and how you can use it in your own
trading so we're gonna take you
step-by-step through trading strategies
and techniques that have made each of us
successful this is me here with the
arrow you can see there's there's five
other people you got Aaron Hunsaker Dan
pastor Riley Jason Leavitt myself agent
Brown and Matt Buckley now benefits for
attending is you know you learn
strategies for trading the bank's
markets and put the payouts in your
pocket and see which stocks make for
great income trades and which to avoid
find out which chart components to look
for discover the top mistakes traders
make and how to avoid them learn how to
use weekly options to trade tactically
short-term for a max profit now you know
this event you know its online but it's
free you can sign up the the link to
sign up go to my website order flow is
calm sign up the link is down below you
just click on it and it'll take you to
the sign up page and the important thing
is you know even if you can't attend you
should register because you know if you
register then you'll be on the list for
the dish the you'll get the access to
the recording alright so I know it's you
know everybody's in sitting in a
different place in the world you know
some are in Asia somewhere in Europe
somewhere in the US and you know this
runs from 11:00 a.m. to 4:15 p.m.
Eastern Time which is New York Times so
you know regardless of where you are in
the world if you miss it so you're
working or whatever you know you gotta
take the kids to school that's fine you
know if you register then you'll get
access to the recordings right and this
one there's actually a little bit
something special you know each each
presenter is after you sign up you will
be taken to a page where you'll believe
you'll get some free stuff I know I
contributed to it I've got a book in
there my hidden trade locations so
definitely sign up for it now again you
know these presentations are for
educational informational purposes only
should not be considered a solicitation
of
I sell a futures contract or make any
other type of investment decision
futures trading contains substantial
risk and it's not for every investor an
investor could potentially lose all and
more than the initial investment risk
Apple is money that could be lost
without jeopardizing one's financial
security or lifestyle only risk capital
should be used for training and only
those with sufficient risk capital
should consider training past
performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results you know
the reason why I put disclaimers in all
my videos is because you know you're not
gonna trade exactly like me or you know
you're not gonna trade exactly like
somebody else that's you know maybe
given a presentation on the state and I
want you to realize that so you know not
all results are gonna be exactly the
same you know there's gonna be a wide
difference you know some people you know
have more time to devote to training or
they just have less time and you know
your results you know is they're
directly correlated to how much time you
you spend on it you know it's not
something that you can just sit down in
fifteen minutes later you know be an
expert at trading no you know it takes
some work so yeah that's why we put the
disclaimer I just want you know you
don't want you to come in with open eyes
and you know you're not getting the
magic bullet so to speak like that you
know yeah you'll learn how to trade
you'll learn some things maybe you could
apply it to your trading that you
haven't you know maybe you didn't think
that hey you know what if I did it this
way I could be a little bit more
successful so that's that's the whole
point of attending these these
conferences that investor inspiration
puts on is you know so you can pick up
and learn new things that you know maybe
you've never even thought of and you
know it could who knows it could make
the difference in your training so again
it's Tuesday September 19th go to my
website to sign up order flows comm
slash sign up and I hope to see you
there on Tuesday
have a great day everyone bye-bye